l'éditeur
[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue sur notre antenne
nouveau numéro de parlement hebdo
l'émission qui revient sur les temps
forts à l'assemblée et au sénat avec tom
tran huy et cette semaine nous recevons
alain joyandet bonjour à jour est cet
homme qui va dresser votre portrait
bonjour alain joyandet
bonjour vous êtes sénateur les
républicains de la haute saône
parlementaire depuis 2002 vous avait
siégé à l'assemblée pendant six ans
avant de rejoindre le gouvernement en
2008 sous nicolas sarkozy comme
secrétaire d'état à la francophonie
sénateur depuis 2014 vous avez été
renouvelé en septembre dernier lors
d'élections qui ont d'ailleurs vu le
sénat conforter son ancrage à droite
alors pour vous quel doit être le rôle
du sénat la proche de l'élection
présidentielle est ce que ça doit être
un rôle plus politique pour porter
notamment projet de l air juste dans mon
portrait vous avez oublié que j'avais
déjà été sénateur en 1995 avant d'être
député benjamin du sénat à l'époque j'ai
donc fait sénat assemblée nationale
sénat c'est pas classique je crois je
puis donc nous ne sommes pas nombreux
dans le vème république
parcours atypique le sénat n'a pas
beaucoup changé depuis c'est pourquoi je
reviens sur cette période de 95 le sénat
doit être avant tout une force de
proposition en ce moment certes aussi
une opposition parce que je pense que en
toute démocratie
on a besoin aussi d'une opposition une
opposition assez forte quand même assez
forte mais l'important c'est que cette
opposition assez forte soit forte aussi
dans ses propositions je pense qu'on y
reviendra dans les différents sujets
mais le sénat propose c'est aussi le
lieu des libertés publiques ici donc
c'est vrai que c'est très subtil parce
qu'on doit être opposant mais bien
expliquer pourquoi on l'est être force
de proposition et on a une ligne de
conduite qui doit être un fil rouge
c'est celui des libertés publiques
à un an de l'élection présidentielle
vous n'allez pas avoir une lecture plus
politique des prochains textes qu'il
s'agisse du climat ou du projet de loi
séparatisme qui conforte les principes
républicains
si vous observez les votes que j'ai émis
depuis maintenant 2014 ici j'ai toujours
ici je suis pas le seul d'ailleurs
garder une indépendance totale de
jugement par exemple dans la sphère de
la pandémie j'ai fait partie de ceux qui
ont voté pour sortir du confinement le
11 mai j'ai beaucoup accompagné le le
gouvernement de monsieur macron les
gouvernements de monsieur macron ça
m'empêche pas d'avoir une opinion très
critique sur la gestion de la pandémie
allez on revient on va justement voir ce
regard sur toute l'actualité de cette
semaine les sénateurs toujours critique
à l'égard de la gestion de la pandémie
par le gouvernement ils en ont débattu
cette semaine dans l'hémicycle de son
côté l'assemblée poursuit l'examen du
projet de loi qui conforte les principes
de la république les députés ont adopté
l'article dit samuel pâtit qui punit les
auteurs de propos haineux en ligne
l'avenir de l'opération barkan en
discussion au sénat
l'opération mobilise plus de 5000 hommes
au sahel alors que les groupes
djihadistes continuent de déstabiliser
la région et on commence cette émission
alain joyandet avec un point sur le
front sanitaire la stratégie du
gouvernement était cette semaine sous le
sceau des questions au sénat
[Musique]
au mois de décembre la commission d'
enquête du sénat a pointé du doigt le
fiasco des masques et l'impréparation
des autorités alors que la france
dépasse les 80 mille morts ils
continuent de faire le bilan et sont
toujours très critique jérôme rallier le
débat réclamé par les sénateurs
promettait d'être musclé dans les avis
divergent entre les élus de la chambre
haute et le gouvernement sur la gestion
de la pandémie
d'emblée alain milon le président de la
commission d' enquête sénatoriale a
pointé l'échec du désormais fameux
triptyque tester tracé isolé sur les
trois pans de la stratégie la constance
mais aussi les moyens ont fait défaut
malgré un développement rapide à
l'honneur des équipes de recherche
le déploiement des tests a connu un
déploiement hésitant et laborieux le
passage au stade industriel se révélant
qu extrêmement complexe c'est sur l'une
des révélations phare du rapport que les
échanges se sont envenimées le sénateur
centriste vincent de l'est fustigeant
les actions du directeur général de la
santé jérôme salomon dans la gestion du
stock stratégie deux masques
dissimulation ma préparation
manipulation trois fautes majeures
aucune responsabilité
malgré cela le gouvernement n'a eu de
cesse de renouveler sa confiance à
direction générale de la santé pourquoi
monsieur le ministre
maintenant que la lumière est faite sur
les erreurs commises quelles
conséquences comptez vous en tirez une
attaque inacceptable pour le ministre de
la santé
je ne crois pas être devant une cour de
justice à répondre d'accusations au nom
de mon directeur général de la santé
donc c'est déjà lui même exprimé sur
cette question là j'ai lu le rapport de
commission denquête les éléments qui
sont qui figurent dans le code dans le
rapport ont été envoyés par le directeur
général de la santé lui-même j'ai déjà
eu l'occasion d'expliquer à plusieurs
fois qu'il avait toute ma confiance et
que je remercie pour l'action qu'il mène
au service de l'intérêt général je vous
remercie
à défaut de mettre d'accord gouvernement
et sénateurs ce débat a permis de se
remémorer les différentes étapes depuis
le début de la pandémie
plus d'un an après son apparition tous
espèrent désormais que le pays serait
mieux armés en cas de survenance d'un
nouveau virus
alain joyandet on a entendu les
critiques dans l'hémicycle à ce que vous
jugez vous aussi que la direction
générale de la santé est fautive qu'elle
a commis des fautes qui nous ont amenés
à ne pas disposer de suffisamment de
masques et qu'il y aurait dû y avoir des
sanctions
moi je pense que la responsabilité
incombe toujours aux politiques
il est trop facile il voulait de 2 de
ceux de montrer du doigt
l'administration si l'administration va
pas bien faut la changer et après on
peut toujours faire un certain nombre de
commentaires mais ce qui est vrai ce qui
d'ailleurs me permet de revenir sur un
point qui me semble très important c'est
que dans cette affaire de la santé comme
sur un certain nombre de sujets c'est la
technostructure qui a pris le pas sur
les politiques sur les pouvoirs locaux
et dans cette affaire la dénonciation
qui est fait peu violente de
l'administration au fond c'est une
carence ses pouvoirs politiques qui
laissent l'administration la
technostructure de l'administration
centrale politique le gouvernement
l'exécutif
aujourd'hui vous savez dans la vème
république le patron c'est le président
de la république nomme des gouvernements
successifs mais le patron c'est le
président de la république c'est comme
ça on peut le regretter
c'est un pouvoir assez solitaire donc ou
bien à un moment donné on se dit qu'il
va falloir regarder cette ce problème de
la technostructure qu'elles soient
françaises ou européennes sur tous les
sujets parce qu'on pourrait parler de
l'agriculture on pourrait parler de
l'intérieur on pourrait parler de
beaucoup de sujets la technostructure en
france et en europe a pris le pas sur
les politiques et donc il nous faut dans
les années qui viennent dans les temps
qui viennent à politique très très fort
qui reprennent en mains le pouvoir
puisque c'est le peuple qui donne le
pouvoir aux politiques peut pas dire
c'est la faute de l'administration est
ce que à l'argent ayant des vous
comprenez le sentiment du ministre de la
santé olivier vers ans qui dit avoir
fait face un tribunal lors de cette
commission denquête bon la commission
denquête n'a pas été un tribunal il ya
deux choses il ya le constat de ce qui
s'est passé pour en tirer des leçons
pour l'avenir
et ça je pense que personne ne conteste
quand même qu'il ya un certain nombre de
problèmes sur les masses sur les tests
l'eba donc je pense qu'il sur la gestion
de la pandémie au sénat est resté dans
son rôle de contrôle de l'action j'ai
reçu
et c'est très important que le sénat
dans son travail ait pu faire l'état des
lieux de ce qui s'est passé c'est quand
même la démocratie on a absolument
besoin de ça et une deuxième partie dans
les travaux du sénat qui concerne les
propositions que fait le sénat je
voudrais y venir notamment sur la
protection des plus faibles si on avait
protégé beaucoup plus vite les plus
faibles on aurait put être été moins
obligé de confiner il ya aussi la
question des pouvoirs locaux tout
organisé depuis paris on voit bien que
c'est très compliqué tout ce qui a bien
marché c'était ce qui était fait au
niveau local on propose au sénat de
renforcer le pouvoir des ars dans les
départements en régions mais bien sûr
l'état à buzz pas que les pouvoirs
locaux
d'ailleurs sont en responsabilité dans
cette affaire mais l'état a besoin aussi
de se déconcentrer
il faut descendre de données de la
direction générale de la santé les ars
régional pour entrer dans les
départements et aujourd'hui est-ce que
alors que nous sommes encore en pleine
pandémie vous jugez que les leçons de la
crise ont été tirés ou est ce que on
continue tout de même à naviguer à vue
un an après bien le début de cette crise
la nique aux convives un peu moins vu
mais encore un peu quand même ça la
décharge du gouvernement est ce que moi
je veux rester très le plus objectif
possible mais en même temps modéré parce
que gérer une crise comme celle là c'est
pas écrit d'avancé
il ya eu des problèmes avant notamment
la disparition des masques et la
nourrice titution des stocks
c'est quand même ce qui a mis le
gouvernement en difficulté ce qu'on peut
reprocher au gouvernement au lieu
général de la santé d'avoir dit hélas on
n'a pas assez de masse mais il en faut
pour se protéger le gouvernement a dit
mais les masques ça sert à rien et dans
un début de gestion de pandémie après ça
vous colle ça vous colle vraiment une
erreur comme celle là cette crise elle
est inédite pour tout le monde un
gouvernement de droite n'aurait pas
forcément fait mieux que le gouvernement
actuel que le politique est un peu
démuni face à ce type de jeu tellement
heureux du gouvernement que nous avons
dû faire face à la crise financière de
2008 qui nous est tombé dessus comme ça
toute vitesse sans qu'on la sent qu'on
s'y attende j'ai vu les difficultés de
gérer
une crise il faut reconnaître que
nicolas sarkozy l'a gérée
particulièrement bien tout le monde lui
accorde cela cette gestion de crise
cette pandémie c'est pas une crise
financière c'est autre chose
est ce qu'un autre gouvernement aurait
fait mieux ou pas je ne sais pas ce qui
est clair quand même c'est que ce
gouvernement n'a quand même pas été
comment dire exemplaire dans la gestion
de la crise et le moins qu'on puisse
dire alors de son problème de madère
olivier ferrand a indiqué que le variant
anglais représenter entre 20 et 25% des
cas qu'il espère toujours ne pas avoir
confiné mais ce que ça vous paraît
aujourd'hui réaliste alors qu on entend
aussi des voix de médecins qui appellent
au contraire art confiné vite et fort
avant d'avoir cette possible flambée
alors moi je soutiens le fait que nous
ne recopie nions pas oui je soutiens le
président de la république dans la
décision qu'il a prise pour une fois
j'allais dire depuis le début de la
pandémie d'être un petit peu indépendant
du pouvoir scientifique de prendre ses
responsabilités comme ça de prendre sur
l'ange dis pas que c'est bien comme ça
parce que dans cette pandémie
on sait pas ce qui se passe dans quinze
jours ou dans trois semaines mais le
fait de tenir et de gérer ensemble la
pandémie sur le plan sanitaire et sur le
plan économique et social
ça me passe on peut espérer alors qu'est
ce que j'espère je croise les doigts
mais moi je ne suis pas scientifique je
suis en politique ce que j'espère c'est
que l'on va pouvoir gérer dans les mois
qui viennent à la fois un apaisement
delà de la pandémie et une relance de
l'économie ce qui pourrait peut-être
nous permettre de tenir jusqu'au
printemps que la fan fin l'abaissement
en tout cas naturel de la pandémie au
printemps coïncide avec ce nom
confinement si on réussit ça on va quand
même comme on dit essayer de l'imiter
j'allais prendre une explosion les dires
survie
c'est à dire mais vous le dit à ma place
j'espère qu'on va pouvoir sauver les
meubles
allez on poursuit avec le débat attendu
à l'assemblée sur le projet de loi pour
conforter le respect des principes
républicains et les députés ont
notamment adopté l'article 18 du projet
de loi aussi appelé article samuel pâtit
le texte crée un nouveau délit celui de
mise en danger de la vie d'autrui par la
diffusion dans un but malveillant
d'informations relatives à la vie privée
explications et comptes-rendus séance
avec thibaut enoch l'article 18 c'est
l'examen factuel des éléments de la
force annuel pâtit un nom sur toutes les
lèvres
samuel pâtit l'assassinât de samuel
pâtit l'assassinât de samuel le pâtis
cet article 18 vise à répondre à ce
crime est un constat partagé par tous
les députés
l'assassinât de l'enseignant dans le nom
avait été jeté en pâture sur internet a
révélé la nécessité de légiférer sur la
haine qui sévit en ligne l'article 18 il
est né avec la faire à semelle pâtit
mais ils règlent tellement d'autres
situations on est dans cadre de ce qu'on
appelle le dock singh des jeunes dont on
révèle un certain nombre d'informations
dont on donne l'adresse lycée le collège
et d'autres ont fait vivre un enfer
tout cela c'est ce que nous devons
changer l'article 18 crée donc un
nouveau délit il vise à condamner la
diffusion d'informations sur une
personne aux fins de lui nuire
une diffusion qui si elle fait peser un
risque direct sur l'intéressé sa famille
ou ses biens sera puni de trois ans de
prison et 45000 euros damende une visée
salué sur tous les bancs mais qui a
suscité des inquiétudes sur la question
des libertés
le grand risque de cet article 7 porté
une atteinte manifeste à l'exercice du
droit à l'information et à la liberté
d'expression évidemment ce qui peut se
poser comme question ici c'est celle de
la flagrance au moment par exemple d'une
manifestation augurer d captation
d'image le garde des sceaux a tenu à
rassurer l'intentionnalité elle est
résumée en quelques mots très simples
s'agit pas de l'intention d'informer
il s'agit je le répète dans l'intention
de nuire les choses sont très claires
au terme des débats l'article 18 a été
largement adoptée pour
nice est contredit des peines plus
lourdes ont aussi été votée si la
victime est un élu un mineur ou une
personne chargée d'une mission de
service public
cette mesure a été votée à la quasi
unanimité des députés présents en séance
ce jour là tire les leçons de ce qui est
arrivé à samuel parti qui avait donc été
victime de propos haineux en plusieurs
jours sur les réseaux sociaux est ce que
pour vous c'était une mesure nécessaire
à voter donc complètement ces mesures
nécessaires aux saveurs on a allumé la
mèche d'un pétard à retardement quand on
a ouvert les réseaux sociaux comme ça
parce que moi je suis que je suis beau
parent dont un ancien journaliste modern
man ancien journaliste bon ont remplacé
journalistes par le monsieur ou madame
tout le monde dans les médias classiques
quand vous disposez d'une information il
ya quand même un moment donné un travail
d'équipé qui dit est-ce qu'on diffusait
ce qu'on ne diffuse pas est ce que c'est
vrai ce que c'est parti il ya des
filtres là on balance sur les réseaux
sociaux à un certain nombre de choses
évidemment sans aucune vérification et
parfois comme l'a dit le garde des
sceaux avec l'intention de nuire un
journaliste qui fait un papier fait pas
avec l'intention de nuire ifec
l'intention d'informer s'ils se trompent
ils rectifient et s'il a essayé de nuire
pour le coup une justice qui se met très
vite en marche parce qu'un rédacteur en
chef et un directeur publication qui
sont devant la justice et qui doivent
répondre
là on n'a pas justiciable on a des on a
des internautes qui peuvent dire
n'importe quoi à toute vitesse vous dit
vous êtes un ancien journaliste est ce
que ce cet article c'est aussi une
nouvelle mouture de l'article 24 de la
proposition de loi sur la sécurité
globale qui pour le coup a suscité une
véritable levée de boucliers notamment
des journalistes parce que il est
contraire à la liberté d'informer a
quand même aussi toutes ces craintes
autour de ces mesures c'est pour ça
qu'il faut garder un bon équilibre
il faut faut absolument canaliser les
excès du grand public je suis désolé de
le dire mais même si je suis dans la
maison des libertés publiques la liberté
ne permet pas faire n'importe quoi au
nom de la liberté et crée des
passerelles problème avec cette année
je pense qu'il faut trouver le juste
équilibre entre régler ce problème là
elle et c'est bien évidemment la liberté
aux journalistes je pense que les
manifestations curieux ont été efficaces
puisque un certain recul a été opéré sur
cet article la adoula les doux aussi la
liberté de manifester quand on n'est pas
d'accord
est ce que c'est une mesure répressive
pour vous et est ce que pour vous voyez
une cible claire dans ce projet loi
notamment dans cette mesure est ce que
l'un site pour vous c'est l'islam
radical l'islamisme radical
même si dans le projet de loi il n'y a
pas une seule fois ce mot toute la
difficulté de la société dans laquelle
nous sommes quand on parle des sujets on
y viendra aussi de des opérations
extérieures des opérations parce que
tout ça pour moi c'est un seul et même
sujet ces deux réussi à trouver la ligne
de crête qui nous permettent de répondre
cet énorme défi qui est celui des
sociétés occidentales par des textes de
loi un certain nombre de dispositifs
sans pour autant remettre en cause la
liberté de tout le monde
quand on parle de l'éducation à domicile
peut être qu'on en parlera à interdire
l'éducation à domicile où la placer sous
contrôle pour tout le monde alors que ça
concerne le problème concerne uniquement
l'islamisme radical
ça pose un sujet donc la difficulté
c'est ça trouver des solutions pour
répondre à la guerre que nous devons
mener sans pour autant réduire les
libertés publiques de tous les autres
qui ne pose pas de problème c'est qu'on
les amalgames namal compas l'amalgamme
mon palais l'islamisme radical avec tous
les musulmans qui désirent vivre en paix
alors il ya un autre point chaud dans ce
texte alain joyandet l'instruction à
domicile le gouvernement veut durcir les
règles de l'école à la maison une passe
d'armes a notamment eu lieu à
l'assemblée avec l'opposition de droite
qui reprochent au ministre de porter un
coup de canif justement à la liberté
d'instruire écoutez c'est son à
l'assemblée dix ans des bancs de droite
comment ne pas être surpris par eux
c'est parle exactement que j'ai entendu
ce que je viens rappeler à l'instant
c'est à dire faire semblant de ne pas
voir que l'instruction en famille a été
instrumentalisé par certains secteurs
faire semblant de ne pas voir que c'est
notre volonté que d'en finir avec ce
phénomène
alors comment est ce que toute la
journée on vous entend plaider contre
l'islamisme radical
supposer que le gouvernement n'en fait
pas assez et le moment où le
gouvernement français problème à bras le
corps alors là d'un seul coup vous
faites semblant de ne pas voir la
réalité terrain
alors qu'est ce que vous répondez alain
joyandet à jean michel blanquer qui va
jouer notre jeu heureusement jean michel
blanc coeur que son travail de ministre
de l'éducation nationale s'est trouvé
une mesure qui mette fin à
l'enseignement à domicile pour
l'islamisme radical parce que c'est ça
le fond du sujet mais que pour ceux qui
veulent faire de l'éducation à domicile
et qui pose aucun problème
il faut leur laisser la liberté donc
pour le plus facile à dire qu'à faire
quand on écrit la loi c'est plus facile
à dire qu'à faire
si l'opposition au créneau c'est sans
doute que le texte n'est pas
satisfaisant pas une mesure nécessaire
pour vous elle est nécessaire contre
l'islamisme radical
il a quand même beaucoup reculé par
rapport à ce qu'il prévoyait au départ
c'est un régime d'autorisation mais on
sent bien qu'il y aura quand même une
certaine ouverture c'est pas suffisant
de la part du gouvernement
écoutez jeu comme je ne peux pas
répondre par oui ou par non à tous les
tous les sujets je me contente de vous
dire qu'il faut trouver la bonne
solution
entre mettre fin à l'enseignement qui
conduit à l'arrivée à la radicalisation
des enfants dans l'islamisme et
permettre à ceux qui ont de bons motifs
de faire de l'éducation à domicile de
pouvoir continuer à le faire
on sent la droite qui défend quand même
beaucoup d'instruction à domicile est ce
que c'est aussi parce qu'il ya beaucoup
de familles qui sont allés dans la rue
notamment des familles catholiques y
votent à droite qui revendique cette
liberté je pense pas enfin tout ce qui
me concerne je veux pas mélanger la
politique avec tout ça on est plus sur
une question de libertés individuelles
il faut que notre société ça revient à
ce que je vous disais tout à l'heure
mais bon quand on est en guerre parce
qu'on est en guerre entre contre
l'islamisme radical et dans toute
période de guerre on a toujours eu pour
gagner la guerre des moments où notre
liberté a été un peu un peu prise en
otage quoi donc il faut qu'on arrive à
trouver l'équilibré
donc pour vous l'école à la maison c'est
à peu près 60 mille élèves qui sont
concernés pour vous donc vous dites
c'est l'islamiste radical qui est qui
qui faut viser il faut viser donc pour
vous ça veut dire qu'on instaure des
raids pour une toute petite minorité
c'est ça que vous dites c'est le risque
c'est le risque d'instaurer puisque on
part on passe d'un régime qui était un
régime de déclaration on déclarait un
régime d'autorisation ça veut dire qu'on
est à priori dans une demande qui nous
ce qui nous est ensuite accordé ou pas
accordées
donc je veux pas condamner le texte de
monsieur blanc caire parce que je sais
que son texte édifie le texte est
difficile à trouver
berlin discute je pense que ça va encore
évoluer
mais bon c'est là aussi où l'opposition
est utile parce que je fais confiance au
parlement et l'assemblée nationale pour
trouver une fille née et puis il y aura
le sénat pyorala il y aura la dib la
navette parlementaire et on va bien
trouver un texte qui puisse rassembler
tout le monde
alors on va terminer à linge à regarder
avec un des sujets que vous connaissez
bien l'opération barkan qui était en
débat au sénat
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors que la france est engagée au sahel
depuis huit ans les sénateurs ont
demandé un bilan de l'opération barkan
de la stratégie à militaire et de la
solution politique
le débat s'est tenu dans un climat très
serein écoutez le ministre de l'europe
et des affaires étrangères jean yves le
drian
puis le président de la commission de la
défense christian cambon parce qu'ils
avaient été défaits au mali nos
adversaires sont passés d'une stratégie
d'implantation locale qui seraient
tentés d'appeler une stratégie
d'occupation territoriales à une
stratégie de déstabilisation régionale
si bien que la menace terroriste s'est
étendu à l'ensemble du sel et c'est
pourquoi en août 2014
nous avons lancé l'opération barkan le
dénouement de cette crise qui dure
depuis huit ans ne sera certainement pas
militaire nous le savons la solution ne
peut être que politique et par
conséquent elle est essentiellement du
ressort des maliens eux mêmes alors
depuis 2013 plus de 50 soldats français
ont été tués au sahel alain joyandet
entre l'opération serval et l'opération
barkan l'opération mobilise encore plus
de 5000 soldats
est-ce que c'est trop est ce que pour
vous la france doit préparer un retrait
progressif
non bien au contraire je pense que ce
n'est pas trop je pense que ce n'est pas
assez
je parle pas pour la présence française
mais je dis que globalement ce n'est pas
assez je pense que l'europe les nations
unies devraient être beaucoup plus en
soutien de tout ce que fait la france
même si la france a des accords de
défense avec un certain nombre d'états
africains plus d'une douzaine on a été
seul sur ce terrain jusqu'ici beaucoup
beaucoup trop passionné mais commence à
lui expliquer pourquoi aussi celle des
jeux l'explication je l'expliquais assez
facilement parce que d'abord ya ces
accords de défense avec la france
je suis passé au gouvernement pendant
quelques années où je m'occupais
justement de ces sujets en afrique
je peux vous dire que on est là au coeur
dans la bande du sahel
on est là au coeur de la sécurité d'une
grande partie du monde
il faut que nos concitoyens en ait
conscience parce que souvent j'entends
dire qu'est ce qu'on fait en afrique où
est ce qu'on s'en va pas non mais quand
on fait du travail là
qui n'est d'ailleurs pas assez valorisés
on voit revenir nos soldats tués
mais on n'a pas les comptes-rendus
d'action de barkan qui sont formidables
parce qu'on ne veut pas trop en dire on
ne veut pas trop en faire on est aussi
dans le secret on est aussi voilà donc
je pense qu on est là dans cet endroit
maintenant je rappelle que depuis ce qui
s'est passé en libye et en syrie
il ya eu un transfert très important des
islamistes en afrique et dans cette
partie de l'afrique tout
particulièrement rappelez-vous ce qui
s'est passé au mali
non je pense qu'il faudrait qu
effectivement la france soit plus aidé
mais vrai que soyons plus nombreux pour
gagner cette guerre qui ne s'arrêtera
pas demain et pour l'instant pour
l'instant je ne crois pas moi à la scea
la solution politique
alors vous n'y croyez pas mais alors
justement ce que la résolution de la
crise ne passe pas peut-être par un
dialogue avec certaines certains groupes
terroristes de la région comme c'est le
cas comme ça a été le cas en afghanistan
et lui aussi je pense que ça ça vient
dans un deuxième temps quand on peut
discuter avec des gens raisonnables
quand on peut discuter avec les gens
raisonnables et qui sonna pardon il y en
a pour vous on a sans doute mais il faut
les trouver
pour l'instant on fait pas face à des
gens raisonnables ont fait face à des
gens qui nous envoient des tirs de
mortier des roquettes et qui tuent nos
soldats il faut quand même pas être naïf
donc pour l'instant la réponse reste
militaire pour l'instant elle reste
militaire écouter ya un groupe qui se
bat uniquement pour le succès mondial de
l'islamisme et du radicalisme et
d'ailleurs quand on écoute le le
commandant de la force française
là bas c'est qu'on rites qui dit
qu'est-ce qui se passerait si on on
quittait le secteur africain qu'est ce
qui se passerait en europe
donc on est à 12 kilomètres de l'afrique
par le détroit de gibraltar il faut
qu'on comprenne bien que gagner la
guerre là bas contre le radicalisme
c'est la sécurité demain de l'europe et
les européens n'ont pas assez conscience
conscience et sont pas assez ne sont pas
assez de vent ou à côté en tout cas la
france et pour répondre précisément à
votre votre question je pense qu'on aura
dans un deuxième temps sans doute à
trouver des gens raisonnables avec
lesquels on peut parler pour faire la
paix des braves
mais pour l'instant on a en face de nous
des terroristes qui veulent nous
éliminer et donc si on si on est naïf et
qu'on baisse la garde
je pense que ce sera très difficile pour
nous en attendant l'armée française est
aussi de plus en plus impopulaire sur
place alors qu'on se rappelle qu'elle
avait été accueillis comme des héros il
ya huit ans pour quoi pour vous y at il
aussi cette défiance des maliens que
l'on sent de plus en plus savez la
france l'ancienne puissance coloniale
donc c'est un rapport très difficile à
gérer avec l'afrique
j'ai aussi constaté cela lorsque j'étais
en charge au gouvernement
quand on s'occupe pas de l'afrique on
nous dit qu'on les laisse tomber et
quand on s'en occupe trop on nous dit
qu'on fait de l'ingérence
donc il faut 30 min indigènes ni
ingérence ni indifférence il faut
trouver c'est encore une fois en
politique c'est souvent comme ça il faut
trouver la ligne de crête et on n'est
pas aussi impopulaire que ça évidemment
les gens qui ne nous aiment pas qui
défilent et qui brûlent les drapeaux on
l'est on les voit bien et bien
évidemment la télévision les millions de
gens qui sont contents que la france et
les européens là-bas forme les armées
africaines forme les airs mais assez
africaine donne beaucoup d'argent pour
la coopération pour développer
l'économie et le social
tout seul on les entend pas assez donc
je pense qu'un certain nombre dit vive
la france en afrique
merci alain jardin merci merci alain
joyandet et on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
parlement hebdo
[Musique]